he is Chris Paulo how are you Chris
that's a nice traffic isn't it thank you
for mentioning that happy holidays
yeah happy holidays to Union what so
what's up with you and Jennifer going on
this very welcome respite Ridge from the
tree trimming process which were in the
middle of it's about a three day process
three days I know Susan is as exacting
and each generator is Jennifer but this
is a has to unfold just so there is a
methodical time-honored routine and plan
for the turning of the tree okay the
lights go on counterclockwise from the
bottom up white first colored after and
we're both actually pretty particularly
detail-oriented so it can be a drawn-out
okay and today's tournaments and yeah
it's been it's been a solid hour of
positioning and repositioning and
squinting stepping back to measure you
know how it looks from a distance and
all angles you know doing this in a
glass box a lot of windows were so we're
just pretty good so so damn long all
right let's take a kind of one step at a
time
so there's a light day and an ornament
day is what are you saying I mean you
need to take a few drinks it's a break
after the lights but he just worked
there we had stuff going on I'm good
it'd be good lights only so now it's
getting pretty close to Christmas is
about time to unbox the ordinance for
the storage unit you haven't spent
Christmas in New York this year so this
stuff is all boxed up and these are you
know it'll like some of an antique
precious ornaments I get bore i rolling
I know but it just kind of take the tree
seriously so I don't know if that's in
your world well in our world we we I get
on a stepladder and I start from the top
yes and then invariably one of the
ornaments that one of our kids puts on
too premature because we're lighting it
up will fall on the ground and break
leading to an all holy heck situation
where one of us steps on it it's
bleeding screaming
yelling and crying and daddys trying to
put the tree to get I mean you know what
I'm saying Chris the most wonderful time
of the year we have a cat to worry about
so we have to specifically place the
ornaments right these least likely to
bat and knock on the ground and break
top and then hope he doesn't climb up
the trunk of the tree which needs to do
the kit and so ok so what's the most
done for you here Chris last one what is
what is the most interesting ornament
that you and Jennifer are putting on on
the tree give me one interesting again
because I'm sure you get a lot from the
college football world
yeah I'm sorry we don't put the the gift
ornaments or the teams and the swag that
doesn't that doesn't make the cut it's a
nice gesture but as I said they might be
in the back of the tree now there's back
of the tree Club back there about it I
don't think you can do get a lot of
ornaments from you get Christmas cards
routines nice but you don't so sorry
cheese it Bowl folks don't send your
cheese and ornaments to Chris and
Jennifer they're in the box that's
fantastic alright so you got three big
games man I mean Alabama Oklahoma I am I
am there with all the popcorn it looks
like two is out of the boot obviously we
saw it on the the Heisman broadcast he's
good he's going right that's there's no
question about that yeah I mean I think
he starts the game pretty close to 100%
in my opinion he won't commit to that
but I think the procedure they did which
is pretty revolutionary pretty new
procedure to go in and actually
surgically deal with a high ankle sprain
not something that was done in the past
accelerates the recovery he's attacking
the the physical therapy and the way you
wanted to see a star player do and I
think you have a ready to go you know
lateral movement we're watching early in
the game where it's his left ankle so is
he pushing off that back foot as he
delivers a lefty throw and committing to
the throw in a way that he wasn't able
to do in the SEC championship game he
heard that thing about the fourth play
and so he wasn't right
holgie and what his right leg eventually
got stepped on that's when he went out
of again but the injury was to the left
one and it affected virtually every
throw that he made in that game so was
it healthy you'd think he'd go back to
throwing the ball the way he was most of
the year and if you're an Alabama thing
you just want to protect that lower body
like don't let a a pass rusher roll up
on it don't step on him if you're an
offensive lineman and just hope that he
can finish the game on a percent how
many oklahoma games did you have this
year Chris we didn't have a Sooners
that's it schedule broke that way yeah
would have would have loved to be able
to do the big 12 championship game but
it wasn't in the cards in the bigger
picture so since you're from Tyler
Mariano sure of course in person just
the first look-see of Tyler and
obviously just knowing how dynamic he is
just watching these have you called a
game where to muscle today I now
so we I've seen it but oh no that's
what's cool what you see a guy game
speed because Carla Maria is a different
speech mm in a big game than he is in
practice he doesn't really let loose
that top gear all the time and he did it
against Texas when he ran for that
touchdown date the first time they
played and if other times this year
you've seen the breathtaking sudden as
the twitchiness that he has but I'm
looking forward to seeing in person I
think Alabama you know it's difficult to
prepare for I told Tyler that is it you
understand that you're really hard to
prepare for right he's a modest guy you
you sort of tried to take that in and
say your arm and the suddenness that he
moves on the ground it is really a rare
rare compliment that's why he's go to
the Heisman Trophy well speaking on
behalf of everyone at the NFL Network
getting ready for the combine in draft
season he's tough to prepare for for us
to Chris Billy Beane with the A's and of
course they're expecting him March 1st
and I ask identity hitting and he's been
on a pause button with baseball so we'd
have to knock some rust off but I don't
know I think he I think he wants to
serve I'm not speaking for him but I
think he's gonna have
some opportunities sort of see what the
NFL thinks of him rich it's no better
than I am
and sort of way it well I mean there's a
reason to try to play both that's for
sure there's a bunch of people that
think well he's not tall enough and he
might not be sturdy enough and then we
see what Baker Mayfield's been able to
do for at about six foot obviously he's
taller than Kyler Murray but I think
Mayfield in the way he's playing is
blazed a trail for calamari someone
might take him first round so I I've
helped his his former teammate that's
great if it's helped other guys who are
not stereotypical NFL quarterbacks sides
I think that's even better
no Kyler's stretches up and stands up
paulie's about 510 I was brilliantly on
the run that's what I think he's got in
common with Baker is not only is he
mobile but while he's mobile when he can
hurt you with his arm and obviously he
can turn it up field and and gobble up
yards in a hurry he's farther from the
NFL prototypes and Baker is for sure but
I think to see this takes one team to
love you right yeah absolutely
Chris Fowler here on the Rich Eisen show
and then the Rose Bowl which is going to
be urban Palooza I imagine every single
Buckeye on planet earth that is free to
come to the Los Angeles area for the
Rose Bowl will be here for Urban Meyer's
last game what are you hearing about
that and and the preparations around it
Columbus this week and some good good
long sit down with there covered a
variety of topics over the years and
obviously an excitement about the end of
the Rose Bowl no one in his staff has
ever been in the road he's never been in
this Stadium really he was recruiting in
Southern California cruised by Pasadena
stood on the outside it was locked that
they wouldn't let him in and he just
checked it out from the parking lot
that's the closest he's been the Rose
Bowl so he's asking a bunch of questions
about it none of his players have been
there it's weird if you think about Ohio
State and all the decades of history in
the Rose Bowl and it seemed like they
were there every year in the seventies
and part of the 80 they've only been
three times in 25 years think about that
and part of it so they've been in
they've been in the BCS games and
they've been in the playoff in years
when they would have played in the Rose
Bowl as Big Ten champs but it's been
that long so yeah you're right it's good
a convention of the Buckeye Nation out
there I think
the fact that it's been a while and
because it's it's their last chance to
retire yeah if you told me a quarter
century ago that uh
Ohio State would only make the next
three Rose Bowls out I said well I know
how many times they lose to Michigan is
what I would have said but we all know
that's a different ball of wax do you
think Urban's done coaching deep down
hard hearts Chris yeah good question I
think he does but things changed we
talked a lot about that I said you know
people are just not gonna believe that
it's 54 when you're out of this for a
while when your health issues and
they're significant when they calm down
if the stress drops if you're not going
to believe that you can manage that and
get back in he says he thinks he's done
he's got some plans when the doctors
used the word risk Ridge that changed
the forum now it's not just enduring the
pain he was in a lot of pain at times I
said it's for real he was just he was in
anguish he looked really uncomfortable
there was a very little enjoyment and
some of those games were in this this
fall cause he was dealing with that
stuff what if it calms down it's stress
going away his life makes him feel
better than who knows but I think that
he's very mindful of his legacy at Ohio
State and I think if he came back in
coaching four years at USC or so from
the NFL yeah it would bother people just
like it really bothered Florida fans so
if he's mindful of that he's gonna stick
around in Columbus if she's gonna teach
a class he's gonna be involved in the
University and some goodwill ambassador
stuff and he says he wants to be around
the players every day
I said well that'll be interesting he's
going to be in the building so we'll
stay out of the way of the next head
tells you said I will I will
he has high regard for Lyon today but
it's gonna be very very rough first year
out of football coaching for him I was
anywhere was for Bob Stoops another guys
all right that I bet I bet and then you
know I might as well just continue
speculating here when you said NFL I
think deep down he's on the craft radar
screen for whenever Belichick wants to
end and if McDaniels isn't there that
that's that's the play I really do
deep down how do you follow politics
though while trying to any admit assists
tough for him dial back in ten
35% maybe I don't know he knows one way
that's been the problem Richie Urban
only knows one way he can't be a CEO he
can't let others run the show or you
focuses on justice things that's just
not it's not possible for him but where
you tell me in the NFL and even I mean I
don't have to recruit right it's a
little bit less 12 months but is it any
less it cancer I can't imagine no it's
not but I mean every single coach that
I've worked with and I'm sure you have
to Chris they can't get out of their
system ever ever ever ever they don't
miss the losing they don't and then as
they get older the the excitement of
winning that emotional high is not
nearly as intense as the depression over
losing but they can't get out of there
since when TV doesn't give you that I'm
ear of a good TV you may need yeah he's
good at you class but I ask myself where
is the fulfillment and the deep you know
satisfaction gonna come where where's
the juice gonna come from I don't know
he doesn't know so that is a good
question before I let you go Chris
Fowler we've been playing a fun game I
think we've it's been out there on the
the Twitterverse where you take the last
place you shopped and then the last
thing you've eaten and add the word Bowl
after it and that's your bowl game so
what is that from you all game yeah last
place I shopped and the last thing IV
yes sir I guess it'd be the the Apple
cereal bowl the Apple cereal bowl okay
so you got an item you got it what kind
of cereal what kind of cereal
tashi or one of those ones it's good for
you but probably isn't okay so golden
you know we predicted it when we didn't
know where you were shopping but we knew
damn sure the food was going to be
healthy we knew that going in I don't
I'm sure but it's almond golden flax
these sounds like it's something that's
so the crisp outer Bowl is the apple the
Apple going ball okay it was the Apple
golden flax Bowl presented by Kashi
that's exactly
Chris fellers bowl man we got ones it
sound like here that hey when we come
back I'm going to play with my - hey
Chris thanks for joining really
appreciate it
yes thanks for coming out - great all
right Chris I hope to get to chance to
see when you're out here in Southern
California we'll chat soon
okay that's Chris Fowler at CB Fowler on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience